(crowd cheering)
- Mine are cheating a little bit.
I'm, I'm quasi cheating.
Thank you for being here!
- Thank you for having me so much.
- You are so talented.
- Thank you.
- You do everything.
- I try.
- Yeah. I'm, I'm very
excited that you're here.
- I like to be busy.
- I know. Me too. I do too.
- Yeah.
- So, tomorrow's Valentine's Day.
So I'm usually pretty low key.
What do you, do you like to go big
on Valentine's Day or do
you like to keep it small?
- It depends completely on what I'm doing.
Sometimes I do like a Gal-entine's Day.
I'll probably be spending
it at home with my dogs
and my girlfriend.
- [Kelly] Fun.
- Very low-key.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That sounds good.
If you did, like, have a
big Valentine's Day plan.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- Like, like a big date.
Is there a particular song
that's like your vibe?
Like your.
- There's an amazing song.
It's like a baby making song.
- [Kelly] Oh. Please do tell.
- Yeah. Is that what you want? Okay.
- I don't want to make
any more babies right now.
No. But I like a baby making song.
- It's a great song.
If anyone in the audience wants to listen.
- [Kelly] What is it?
- It's, it's a YouTube.
It's not, you find it on YouTube.
She's called Akua Naru.
- [Kelly] Akua Naru.
- Akua Naru. It's called,
"Poetry: How Does it Make You Feel?"
Listen to it. Babies will be made.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Babies will
be, I might not listen.
- Name them Cara, if I am right.
- Name them Cara.
I will not, I will be skipping
that song just in case.
So what about a favorite like breakup?
Do you, do you go to
like any artist or song?
Like if you're having
like an emotional time?
- Yeah. Alanis Morissette,
"You Outta Know".
- [Kelly] Oh, well that's.
- [Cara] Come on.
- [Kelly] How do you. I
don't think a song has
beat that one.
- No. My friends call me Janice
because it's my alter ego.
I just kind of like, yeah.
Scream it. Yeah. Yeah. It's great.
- Well, if you don't then
there's something wrong with you.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- That's what the song is for.
- [Cara] Yeah. It's the best song.
- Yeah. She gave us a
vessel and we're using it.
- [Cara] We're using it. Believe. Yeah.
- You're, I mean, you're an actor,
you're a model, you're a musician.
You're like, you love writing.
- Yeah.
- Like do you write as an outlet?
I'm just curious because
you do so many art forms.
- I do.
I wasn't very good at school,
so writing to me was always
something I thought I
was bad at, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think school always puts that pressure
on you to make you feel like
maybe you're not as good
as you think you should be.
Or being smart.
You have to be smart to be a good writer.
You really, you don't,
not saying I'm not smart.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Cause I am. But um,
- No, they do.
They put certain guidelines
in the curriculum. Yeah.
- Yeah. And I think writing
made me realize that like,
all these emotions I was feeling inside
I never really expressed
them until I started writing.
And so it's been just one
of the biggest saving graces
for me in so many ways.
I use it all the time.
- Me too.
- It's usually sad.
Someone's like, oh my God, you write,
you should read me something.
And I read them something,
they're like, blubbing.
I'm like, that's not.
- [Kelly] They're like, are you okay?
- That's not what you want. I'm so sorry.
- Yeah. But that's why I write.
I think it's like, that's
why I started writing poetry
when I was a kid just to
get your emotions out.
'Cause I had a hard time communicating.
Funny enough.
- [Cara] Me too.
- Now I have a talk show.
(high-five clapping)
- Yes.
- So, I did. I never talked.
I kept everything inside
and they told me to talk
and then I never stopped.
So is it true that you
have a recording studio?
Like when you travel?
- I do.
Yeah. I have, I have a
little recording studio box.
That I just pull out.
- It's cool 'cause nowadays
with technology you can do that.
Like anywhere.
- Yeah. Bedroom producers.
- Yeah.
- It's great. You can
do it on the loo, even.
- And you get, you can, I've,
actually, when you do it
in the bathroom, the
acoustics are kind of cool.
It's like natural verb.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I've done that.
- Add that in.
- Yeah.
- I really want, I would
love one day to release song.
Be like, so I made this on the toilet.
- I know, if I'm ever listening
to your song and I hear.
- It's not a (censored) song, though.
- Yeah. I hear someone peeing.
I'm like, ah. Nice
stream of consciousness.
- Yeah. I love that.
- So, see what I did there?
I heard that when you play piano
that you have a beautiful
piano at your house
and when you play, you do
something in particular.
When you play, you like
to play it a certain way.
- Yeah. Naked.
- That's amazing.
- Yeah.
- But I don't have a problem with it.
- No, me either. I love.
- It's very free.
- That's how we're born, guys.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, congrats on the new
season of "Carnival Row".
So for those who haven't seen
it, how would you describe it?
- It's kind of this like
neo-Victorian steam punk world.
It's obviously real, realistic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Cara] I play a fairy. That's me.
Called Vignette Stonemoss.
I'm a fae.
So it's kind of set in
like, it's basically based
on the fact that like
creatures are, you know,
being taken over and taken to this place.
And it's kind of us,
up to us to stop them.
But it goes quite heavily
into like the kind of politics behind it.
But the creatures, the,
the special effects are all so incredible.
And it's really.
- People are so talented.
- Yeah. And, but it's amazing
to watch it 'cause it's like,
it has quite a large social commentary
which isn't quite obvious
until you watch it.
- But that's the cool
thing about art is you
slip it in there.
- Yeah. You're like educating
people but like subtly.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Through steampunk.
- Entertainment. Yeah, steampunk.
- Exactly. I like it.
So were you ever into, I'm
like, I'm still the magical,
I love magic.
I believe in magic. I think it's real.
- I do magic.
- You do? I love it.
So do you, were you that kid?
Did you have like imaginary friends? Like.
- I, I was jealous of other
kids that had imaginary friends
so I would try and make it happen.
But then I was like, I
have voices in my head.
I'm not alone.
- I'm not, there's so many people in here.
Oh my God, we're so similar.
- It's fine. Yeah.
- All of us in here
having such a good time.
- It's like, I don't need to see them.
They're just in there.
I can't like put that here.
But I was kind of like,
I always started to try and
pretend to talk to people.
Imagining they're there and then people
just thought I was crazy.
So I was like, I don't understand.
I'll just keep them inside.
- I'll just keep it all in here.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Hey guys.
Until you, you're letting
it out through music.
- I brought them with me.
- [Kelly] I brought them
with me. They're all here.
- Bill.
- Say hi to Joe.
Do you still tend to make
things up in your head now?
I'm very much like, sometimes I talk
to my therapist about like,
like fantasy can be so fun.
I don't even mean like dirty.
Well that could be fun too,
but I just mean like.
Whatever floats your boat.
But I just mean like sometimes
creating, I don't know.
I feel like I did that when I was a kid.
- Imagination is the
most incredible thing.
- [Kelly] It is such a gift.
- And I think as we get
older, we get jaded and you
stop doing that.
- [Kelly] I'm not.
- I'm not.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. At all.
- But then, 'cause sometimes
I was like, wait, do I have.
If I could make all the voices,
'cause there's not loads of voices
but sometimes you have
like a negative voice.
Sometimes it's like, you know
you're nice to yourself
depending on, and I was like
if I could make them talk
at the same time.
Know what, they can't.
So I'm not schizophrenic, thank god.
But one thing I can do
is I can play a song
and have someone talking over it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Try it.
- I will. Try it right now.
It's like. I love it.
So wait, what, what steps have you been?
Who are all these people?
But that's what makes you
exciting and not boring.
That's what I tell myself.
- Unpredictable.
- Yeah. Unpredictable.
I, I hear that you've been
on a kind of a journey.
A self-discovery journey.
- Yeah.
- I feel like I'm always on one.
I feel like we're always ever changing
and if we're not, we're boring.
- I feel like no matter
what, throughout your life
your, like, healing is
the most important thing
in the world no matter what.
And like, mistakes are
meant to be made and,
but the thing is about mistakes
is if you learn from them
they can be the greatest lesson.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You can't learn from anything
better than mistakes.
So, I mean I've always been
on that journey but I
think I've just been young.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I know.
- That's not the excuse.
There isn't an excuse,
but that's more just like it's really.
- I don't believe in
regrets because of that.
- No, I don't have any regrets.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- But it's really interesting
'cause you kind of have
to take a step back
and realize what's important in life.
- Absolutely. Perspective is nice.
- [Cara] I love perspective. Changing.
- Me too. And I, I love being.
- Yeah. Changing your
perspective is fantastic.
- It is. I agree with you.
- So, dude, I'm so sorry.
Every time, I forgot, I
never wear bright colors
and so every time I look
down I'm like, oh my God
it's so shocking down here.
- It's so rocking'
- (censored)
- Rocked out and it,
yeah, you look like you're
in a music video. Yeah.
- [Cara] Oh cool.
- Well you kind of probably look that
at target like, but yeah, yeah.
- [Cara] No. No I do not.
You wouldn't recognize me.
- It's like a daily thing for you.
- [Kelly] I'm sorry. Yes, I would.
Your eyes are mesmerizing.
I'm trying to not pay attention to them.
It's, it's like you, it's
like a bug to a light.
They're so pretty.
- Look at your eyes, baby girl.
- I'm just saying.
Did your new documentary help
you with your self-discovery?
It's Planet Sex, right?
- Yeah. So basically
with that documentary,
I didn't realize how much this discovery
of the world and everything else
around it was actually really
a journey within myself.
- Yeah.
- So for me it was like
going through that, I was,
I thought I knew everything
about myself and I didn't.
There was so much left
to kind of discover.
Good, bad. Like all of
these things started coming
up and that's kind of where, like,
in a way doing it on TV was kind of weird.
That was kind of the weirder part.
Because I was like, wait,
this is a lot of personal
things I didn't really
realize I would be
expressing or going through.
So that's kind of what I afterwards.
- But that's cool 'cause
we're all very similar.
- No, it's amazing. And
I think, yes. We are.
- I think we're far more similar.
Like when somebody says
something, they're like
I can't believe I said that out loud.
I'm like, most of us probably think that.
- Yeah.
- We just don't say it out loud.
I love the show, though.
What did you discover on the show?
- I kind of discovered that I
was still so much a student.
In life, I'm always gonna be that.
- [Kelly] That's good.
- But learning that I didn't
(censored) know it all.
Oh (censored). And again.
- It's okay, we bleep it.
- I discovered that this world is so vast
and magical and if you ever feel alone
there are people in this
world who will understand you.
And that is one of the gifts
we get from like communication
and especially with the internet
which obviously can be bad
sometimes with, with that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like I always felt
alone when I was going
through stuff, but now I'm
like, what's the point?
- I think we all do.
Which is kind of silly.
Like I felt like that
a lot when I was a kid.
- But that, it's, your brain
is trying to sabotage you
'cause it's like you're alone,
you're going through this alone.
But it's like you gotta get
out of that little thing.
- Yeah. You just totally went cross-eyed.
- Yeah.
- No, I think it is
getting out of our own way
and letting our ego go.
- Yeah. Gotta get outta that ego.
- [Kelly] I know. I get it. I get it.
- Kick it.
- Well, taking a turn.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- I hear that there's also a
skill that you've discovered
that you have and it doesn't have to.
- [Both] Do with me naked.
Yeah. No. Not (mumbling).
(both laughing)
I love you so much.
So you do this.
So you can read lips.
(both laughing)
(audience laughing)
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna pee my pants.
(both laughing)
Wait,
Season 2 of Cara's show,
so you can,
are you,
(both laughing)
Are you guessing what I'm saying?
(Audience clapping)
How do you know?
Can you read lips or minds?
(both laughing)
Please say you do this when
you're on a date with someone.
Have you?
(Kelly laughing)
Oh my god.
I swear to god, I might've
pee'd a little bit.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
- No. So basically it's 'cause
I think I lip read but also,
I, my brain works so fast
'cause of what, a 'ADHD' Sure.
Yeah. But, so I can kind of
guess what you're gonna say.
- Okay.
- You're so predictable, you know?
- Okay, well damn.
- I'm joking, I'm kidding.
- Hate to hear it.
- Especially when you
are doing it to someone.
- Yeah.
- People get really thrown
off so it's quite easy.
- So you can kind of,
- Americans are easier to copy
- Okay
- Than English people 'Cause you guys talk
with the front of your mouth.
Like you go, you really
talk with your lips.
So it's like
- I do.
- Yeah.
- Well,
- All Americans,
- I'm not normal from
like most Texans though.
- Oh yeah.
- Most, most Texans like, it's just
like they open their
mouth and it's like one
long,
- like English people talk more back here.
So it's like, and it's
less like in the front.
Oh, so it's just easier.
- No, we're very expressive.
- It's good.
- It's a, it's an amazing
- No but then people trying,
people try not move their lips.
I can't do that.
But it's you.
Yeah. I got that was
'cause I didn't think it
was gonna work. Sometimes it,
- That was one of my favorite
things to ever happen.
Not only on this, show but in life.
- Good.
- Like, I'm gonna totally
mess with someone and do that.
- No, But when people, when
people are like drunk or stoned
or whatever it really freaks them out.
You really can't do that to people.
- Oh my God. you'll
send them into a panic.
- Send them into a whole state.
They're like what?
- And they're like people
- The Matrix or whatever
- Matrix.
They're gonna start
doing this at the table.
Oh my god.
I love you so much.
Season 2 of Cara's Show "Carnival Row"
starts streaming February
17th on Pride Video
and her docu-series "Planet
Sex" premieres tomorrow on Hulu.